This year's Nobel Prize in Physics has been awarded to three scientists...
...for an invention that has started to reshape how we light our lives: the blue LED.
The prize was awarded to a trio of Japanese scientists...
...who in the 1990s developed the blue LED...
...which, when combined with red and green LEDs, led to white LED light.
That enabled the use of LED lighting to light homes...
...which could greatly reduce energy consumption,...
...as LED lights last much longer and are much more efficient than traditional light bulbs.
The initial invention of the high brightness blue LED is credited to Professor Shuji Nakamura,...
...who developed it at Nichia Corporation Japan,...
...one of the world's largest manufacturers of LED lights.
Nakamura eventually left Japan and gained American citizenship,...
...which led a number of American outlets...
...to describe the prize's announcement Tuesday like this.
The Nobel Prize in Physics has been awarded this morning.
It's gone to two Japanese and one American scientist.
An American scientist is among the recipients of this year's Nobel Prize in Physics.
Well, we're not disputing the fact that Nakamura is an American citizen.
...outlets seemed pretty eager to claim him as such,...
...neglecting the fact that Nakamura has spent almost all his life in Japan,..
...where he created his award-winning invention.
Anyway, if you need proof of the wide reach of Nakamura's invention...
..and you have a smartphone, the light it uses as a flash for your pictures...
...or as a flashlight comes from that combination of red, blue and green light.